hi I'm Max Keiser this says the Kaiser
report can you feel it
halloween is coming ghosts goblins but
mostly ghosts and speaking of ghosts let
me give you a quote here from Thomas
Jefferson peeper is poverty it is only
the ghosts of money and not money itself
yes and this is a good time of the year
to talk about this and a good time of
the I guess the decline of the Fiat
Empire that is the US dollar debt and
we've seen over the past few years
especially in the past year we've
covered that nations like China and
Russia are stockpiling gold rapidly we
saw Germany bring back their gold
repatriate their gold from the New York
Fed over the past few years thanks to
Max Keiser by the way just google that
to find out how we instigated that we
see the likes of Netherlands and other
nations also retrieving and repatriating
their gold from overseas holdings so
there is a sense that nation states that
central banks are starting to be spooked
about the value of their fiat Holdings
and in fact I'm going to turn to a tweet
suggesting this that there may be a
regime change on the horizon regime
change gold reserves have been spiking
since May while US Treasury holdings
keep tumbling worldwide so as you can
see some time last year central banks
around the world got spooked by their US
dollar holdings and started to pare them
back and their gold holdings spiked so
this is the beginning of the spooking
you know what's really scary a negative
interest rates you know I'm gonna go out
Halloween trick-or-treating this year
I'm gonna wear a costume of negative
interest rates and whenever I go and
knock on people's doors they're gonna be
scared out of their wit's they're gonna
be like
and you know that's the thing central
bank's once they see negative interest
rates and you know it was a novelty at
first and then became mainstream policy
new 15 trillions now seven eight nine
trillion dollars worth of negative rate
bonds and so to respond to this scary
you know paper is poverty says Thomas
Jefferson it's only the ghosts of money
think about what his comments would be
about negative interest rates because a
negative rate is less than paper it's
worth less than paper so it would be
negative interest rates are beyond
poverty worse than poverty it's it's not
only the ghosts of money but it's the
ghosts of a ghost of money and then you
know it's just like so freaking scary
that these central banks are are hitting
the Buy button in a huge way that's why
gold has made new all-time highs against
currencies all over the world including
the euro in the pound and the yen and
the Indian rupee the dollar is lagging
but that's high will be taken out
probably in the next six months negative
interest rates are also a ghost of time
maybe in the future of children now
going real children trick-or-treating I
know where they only the oldest people
at trick-or-treating every October 31st
but you know it'll only be they won't
have ever seen interest rates they won't
ever have known a time when time had
value there is no value to time and that
is frightening because we as humans
measure almost everything by time
imagine going trick-or-treating and
you're given from the person out the
door empty wrappers and they tell you
come back next year for the candy okay
that's the negative interest rate and
they're only going to give you half the
candy so they're gonna guarantee you
less candy next year if you accept the
wrapper today that's what a negative
interest rates all about you're
guaranteed to lose money over time so
there's no such thing as trick-or-treat
anymore there's no such thing as a treat
where time has no value it's all trick
it's all trick it's all trick we're
living in a trick bag because who are
the tricksters
and those are the the operators of the
derivatives machine those who who whip
up this poverty of paper they're the
ones that create the poverty we see it
around the world the results of it
protests erupting in places like Beirut
and Chile in the past there's awesome
do-good around the hood that's gonna
give you an apple and like this apples
good for you you're like you throw the
Apple away just organic
trick-or-treating throw it away it's in
the woods you know give it to a squirrel
you know don't bother with that now it's
not even that's that would be considered
a vast improvement over empty wrappers
that are guaranteed to give you less
candy at some time in the future part of
this complex of Treasury Holdings of US
assets the paper assets that investors
outside of the US are definitely spooked
about they're dumping those holdings
they're buying gold because they're
spooked they want real hard assets not
you know ethereal ones like the the
ghost that is the dollar and other fiat
currencies part of what we've seen is a
real spooking in the repo markets and
that's the overnight cash market so this
should be very liquid right but it's not
and that's when interest rates spiked up
to 10% a few weeks ago in the overnight
market so the Fed has stepped in to
rescue the markets again to comfort all
the spooks people the spooked investors
and the headlines and the financial
press have kind of moved on but in fact
is getting worse in the real world the
real crazy stuff happening out there and
the dark pool of bad toxic debts out
there the repo markets are not only not
getting better
today the Fed is supplying two hundred
and five billion dollars of repo taking
out the quarter and peak of two hundred
and two billion set on September
thirtieth repo needs more and more Fed
medication to stay calm that was from
Friday when the Fed stepped in with two
hundred and five billion dollars you
know the repo market is the real horror
film and you know in all these horror
films these teen horror films there's
always the team
they're always doing the worst thing
right like they go into a haunted house
and there's a car there it's running and
it's pointing to the exit and then
somebody says let's get in the car and
drive away and somebody says no we have
to go into the haunted house right they
make the worst choices so they're going
to keep doubling down on this repo
market even though that's the worst
possible choice that could make now
according to James grant over there at
the grants interest rate observer he
observes that what's being built as a
insolvency problem or a liquidity
problem is actually a debt problem so
they are creating trillions and
trillions and trillions of debt going
back to the 2008 global financial crisis
and the interest on the debt has to be
serviced with some cash even they've at
a point oh-o-oh one percent coupon and
the repo market is showing us that they
can't even pay the interest on the debt
with cat they're running out of cash to
even pay the paucity of interest on the
debts that they're creating to bail out
the banks it's one big rolling nightmare
bailout of banks so as he points out
this debt should be reduced if you want
to cure the problem get rid of the
ghosts of money as Jefferson might say
but instead like the bad horror film
there are solution as create more debt
yeah and actually to continue with this
horror film idea is these repo markets
are suggesting that banks don't trust
each other because they know they've
walked into the haunted house that is
our global financial system and you know
in a horror film like who's the first
one that's going to like get eaten by
the ghost or killed by Freddy or Jason
or something like that it's like there's
always some bimbo
who gets knocked off by the the bad guy
first right and you don't want to be
that person so nobody trusts anybody
nobody trusts who's the actually maybe
the haunted person whose is first in the
ghost are they going to run off with my
assets and so that's my analogy the
continuation of your analogy but the
horror film is nobody trusts all the
players in this haunted house well you
know I'll give another analogy would be
Bruce Lee I think it centered the dragon
where he's it goes into the house of
mirrors and he ends up smashing all the
mirrors that he's kind of like fighting
himself because he's he's his own
reflection so here you know here you
have these banks going
this house of mirrors because all the
debt refers to other debts since we
entered the era of modern fiat money
that's self referential and referring
other fiat money we've dropped a gold
standard we have this very interesting
situation where there is no beginning to
the cycle it's just all infinite regress
each fiat money is standing on the
shoulders of another infinite money
I'm sorry fiat money until you have this
enormous Morpheus strip of fraud
committed by global banks and the result
now is that it's snapping shut and they
can't print the money fast the fake the
ghost money they can't print it fast
enough to stop the repo the very
short-term end of the market from
jumping and showing massive red light
problems that the ax murderer is it is
Nicholson in the shining he's come
through the bathroom door with the ax
here's the repo market and you know the
central bankers are saying print and of
course it's the guaranteeing their death
let's stick with this because one thing
I never understand I really don't like
horror films that are around zombies
because it's like just outrun that right
like they run they walk so slow and you
know there are scientists who have
actually deciphered these films of how
dumb the notion of a zombie is but now
we're seeing that we actually can't even
outrun these zombie deaths this ghost
money like we've been running so fast
printing so fast as you said and still
this zombie is still like lurking and
ready to eat the whole global economy
and in fact the IMF is just warning that
corporate debt is now at 19 trillion
like twice where it was in 2008 at the
beginning of the financial crisis and
40% of those companies can't pay the
interest on their debt out of current
earnings so those are zombie companies
40% of corporations out there are zombie
corporations at the moment so it's like
the zombies are taking over more and
more and there is slow motion and we
can't outrun it
right well just all started in Japan
right the notion of the zombie bank
start
in Japan where banks were unable to
service their own deaths and that they
were on a permanent tether to the
central bank to pay off their debts and
that zombie Bank migrated to other
countries around the world now we have a
global central bank zombie central bank
system and we have zombie corporations
we have a zombie economy and we have
executives that corporations buying back
their own stock as fast as they can
because they know that these companies
are are technically insolvent that's why
we're seeing so many bankruptcies so
many so many economic corporate like the
we work would never made it to an IPO
because it was functionally a zombie
ghost company continuing on this theme
of paper is poverty
it is only the ghost of money and not
money itself I want to continue with
that theme of what Paul Krugman says is
that debt is money we owe to ourselves
and of course we owe it to ourselves
ie the next generation and in this sort
of trick-or-treat moment why we're being
haunted by this debt it is the
Millennials in the Generation Z who are
the youngest coming on right now into
the workforce they're haunted by the
basically the lives that boomers had ie
the first into this global debt pyramid
there in order to sustain all their you
know high levels of debt they have to
accumulate massive amounts of student
debt credit card debt auto loan debt is
huge now health care debt all these
medical debts like the this is a this is
the younger generation being haunted by
the the lives that became came before
them and who are the Predators on the
sidelines ready to vulture the poor
students in debt oh it's the military
recruiting complex they'll be like oh
you've got debt we've got a job for you
go kill those people and as Ben pointed
out many times now the people who are
going into these wars to pay down their
debt don't even know why they're who the
enemy is yeah totally generic we'll talk
about that in the next episode I have a
headline about that but right now I want
to finish up on saying in terms of this
debt that is haunting the new generation
and tie it up finally wrap this up with
your analogy of the haunted house that
all these kids these teenagers walk into
is that as what we're seeing on the
political sphere domestically here is
that nobody knows they're all doing the
dumb thing they're not leaving the
haunted house they have a choice to go
into the haunted house and just leave
but they always go into it and nobody
knows how to not go into this haunted
house nobody knows a way out of this
horror film maybe the only solution is
to make Woody Harrelson President of the
United States all right we're gonna take
a break when we come back much more
coming your way welcome back to the
Kaiser report I'm max Kaiser time now to
go to London speak with Ross Ashcroft
and he's a renegade inc.com he's also
the director of everyone do you remember
the four horsemen a film that came out a
few years back I see on YouTube it's got
eight and a half million views Ross that
was a smash hit welcome back to the
Kaiser report thank you very much max
it's cuz you're in it it was
oscar-winning that performance everyone
talks about it is do you stole it
of course now let me get into some
serious questions here about the Serious
Fraud Office that in okay they've ended
their inquiry that ended their inquiry
into the LIBOR rigging scandal the
evidence in the case was pretty
straightforward it seemed and
substantial and it led directly the
evidence led directly to Mark Carney in
the Bank of England what happened I
think that what you begin to realize in
the UK and the UK banking system at the
moment is when you start to pull one of
the roots of what's really going on it
runs so deep into the rest of the system
that you begin as a regulator or as a
legal system to understand the
ramifications of those roots and what
would I say I'd say that if one person
begins to manipulate LIBOR the rest of
the market basically has to do the same
thing so I think the corruption within
that system that and the people who are
working with it was phenomenal
I think it was incredibly difficult now
I think it is incredibly difficult now
for the justice system and the
regulators to address the
sighs and the scope of it and quite
interestingly because they came out and
have these statements that the Serious
Fraud Office make and what this one is
that following a thorough investigation
and a detailed review of the available
evidence there will be no further
charges brought in this case the
decision was taken in line with the test
in the Code for crown prosecutors now in
that code think about a couple of things
one realistic conviction but two is this
in the public interest well if the
public have been overpaying for their
financial products for however many
years my suggestion is that this is very
much in the public interest I think that
comes with a different conclusion it
also aided and abetted financial fraud
wide-scale what's now being looked at in
America with JP Morgan and the
manipulation of the precious metals is
being prosecuted under Rico the
anti-racketeering law in the UK the same
thing was going on with the Bank of
England part of the racket remember in
2008 when the financial crisis hit the
banks were claiming that we just need
liquidity it's not an insolvency because
we've got plenty of assets on the books
including all this property of course
the only way we can save the property is
if you the Bank of England manipulate
interest rates down that is the same
move money from the savers who have
their money at the banks paying an
interest you move that money or steal
that money Mark Carney and put it into
the pockets of the bankers who can then
be prevented from having to write down
the fact that they've got huge losses in
the property market and it's a massive
racketeering fraud that Mark Carney is
guilty of racketeering just like Jamie
Dimon is also guilty of racketeering as
I see it and I've been right for ten
years in a row haven't been wrong yet
let's move on to the Financial Times
they write quote botched outsourcing has
cost the UK taxpayer fourteen billion
dollars now of course botched is a
euphemism
used in the UK to buy the
stiff-upper-lip crowd and the BBC to
avoid having to use a word like
fraudulent
even though it is fraudulent by any
standard of free speech but of course
this sort of plunder is not new in the
UK as you're pointing out there's a lot
of it what about that yellow vest style
movement against it in the UK Ross when
are we going to see that we might have
an unlikely cheerleader because Megan
Markel recently is struggling apparently
with the stiff British upper lip so
maybe she's cooled the mood but what
you're seeing in the UK is people can
take it for so long there is a stoicism
around the British people but once they
get an understanding of what's been
really going on and you use the word
botched and other people have used what
Bosh let's use the proper terminology
this is the business model it's
corporates sitting with governments and
lining each other's pockets government
awarding contracts and then suddenly
people are incompetent and we know that
people are incompetent and corporates
are we know people competent certainly
incompetent in government's but
basically we don't get away from the
fact that these this is the business
model and we're and taxpayers realise
that this is the business model when
they realize that they've been ripped
off while the financial system again
when they realise that they've been out
doing a shift and their bankers and the
parasitical elements of the economy
haven't that's when you'll start to see
the Furman and and the anger and people
asking more fundamental questions and I
wouldn't be surprised if they're out in
the street before too long because they
have been pushed so so hard the British
are a tolerant and reasonable Bunch
but once you push that once you push
them too far then the ramifications can
be huge last time I saw any real
pushback was the poll tax you know under
the Thatcher era this is often referred
to as a moment when Brits finally said
we've had enough and they revolted in a
huge way but they tend to be as you say
complacent and but you know you
mentioned Megan Market the hall is kind
of an aside but apparently Prince Harry
is at odds with his brother William and
maybe we're gonna see a Westminster exit
a Westminster is it you know and that is
symptomatic of a real problem in
cohesion over
in the UK but unlike Chile Beirut Haiti
Spain and what we call the global
insurrection against banker occupation
the British people are still kind of
sitting on their hands
I guess just hoping this whole thing
just goes away and things resume back to
excuse the pun I don't think the pennies
quite dropped and I think that in 2008
people saw what really gone on in the
banking system and then what we had was
alerted QE QE was there to buy time we
were gonna buy time so we could
structure fix the structural problems in
the economy guess what we bought time we
didn't fix anything we didn't fix any of
the structural problems the British
people are starting to wake up to that
now they're starting to realize that
2008 in a sense was a dress rehearsal
and this is coming again there's way too
much debt there people pushed wages are
still stagnant and and they're starting
to realize that the policymakers the
bank because and the politicians haven't
done a thing and that's when you start
to see people really asking fundamental
questions getting out on the street and
asking for direct action and to the
point you know the make a mark a point
you know the establishment is under an
enormous amount of strain at the moment
all over the world but specifically in
Britain and the reason they've lied for
too long and thought that they could get
away with it and they could for a long
time they could get away with it and
they could take the rents and they could
manipulate rates and all the missed sell
and all the rest of it but ultimately
what we're about to see in Britain is
what Robert Louis Stevenson called the
banquet of consequences and because
those things haven't been fixed
structurally you're about to see people
understand that actually my economic
future has been stolen and at that point
at that point who knows what's gonna
happen because otherwise tolerant
British people won't be right I would
have thought that when it was shown
through a in phrase
but about Royal Bank of Scotland and
subsequent reports that the Royal Bank
of Scotland RBS had looted 30,000
British corporations their own customers
yes that that would have led to some
soul-searching about the four big banks
in the UK and their their commitment of
what I call financial terrorism people
now calling it financial vandalism but
let's call financial vandalism because
that's the the current phrase used
people are now but you know we've been
following this space for a long time
Ross and we're now at a point where
people are no longer trying to justify
this under some arcane II policy or
economic model they are now realizing
and it's used in the popular press this
is vandalism Ross the temerity for me is
absolutely huge because back in the day
you know people used to say well we're
going to try and cover this up and we've
made as you know lots of programs at
renegade RBS and other banks and it's
very simple this is their business model
there wasn't any liquidity left in the
system so what do they do they turned on
their own people it's a very much an
Empire State of Mind the rent seekers
turned on their own people and what they
did is they systematically looted
businesses where there is a nursing home
a hotel a golf course a property
portfolio you name it everything was up
for grabs and then there's those assets
were sold at bargain basement prices to
vulture funds around the world and and
it was that flagrant and that obvious
now the question is how do they get away
with that how possibly do you get away
with that in the c-suite of a bank or is
something else at play has somebody else
got your back
it's the establishment saying actually
we're out of money we know your taxpayer
owned now RBS so we need to get this
money back through so anything's fair
game and I'd like people to think about
that and certainly think about it if you
go before going to bank with any of
those organisations because it isn't
just that your home is at risk if you
don't keep up repayments your home is at
risk even if it's paid for and that now
is the business model when that penny
drop
I think you're going to see in the UK
the kind of protest
you haven't seen can forget I think that
will make the poll tax riots look like a
walk in the park are you mentioned the
business model of looting and it's
primarily in the Conservative Party
going back to Thatcher's day and this is
what's happening offer financialization
isn't this the primary motive of those
seeking brexit is to enable more looting
Ross deregulation and to be cut from the
UK to become Singapore on terms which is
a ludicrous idea is absolutely top of
the agenda and if you're gonna say to me
which is the one organisation that is at
the top of that agenda
it's the NHS because American and other
healthcare insurance companies and
healthcare companies globally have got
their eye on it because they know how
profitable that can be rice is the
answer right very good
well thanks Ross for being on the Kaiser
report well that's gonna do it for this
edition of the Kaiser report with me Max
Keiser and Stacy Herbert like to thank
our guest Ross Ashcroft of renegade Inc
commies want to catch us on Twitter it's
kinds of report until next time bye
you
[Music]